now to Ed Sheeran ed is letting cameras
inside his private world and he'll have
a new documentary to show for it and I
talked to Ed about that but first I
needed an update about his most
important gig to date his own wedding
now I did see on your Instagram that you
told someone that you're already married
a silent shrug never said so much break
sooner said break some news
edy stopped short of confirming his
marital status with cherish Seaborn but
he did refer to the wedding in past
tense I never wanted a wedding that was
loads of people I don't like large
groups of people at the best of times
your fiance / wife did appear in the
documentary Hey anything okay that's a
big step because you are so private so
what does that like I said it was wins
it was weird to me weird for me his
Apple music documentary songwriter is
streaming now the film shows the behind
the scenes journey of writing his Grammy
winning album divide
I love to sing like the little add
videos well that's the first time I've
seen them as well I do look very
different very different it's also
hinted at a secret collaboration and a
budding new bromance with fellow Grammy
winner Bruno Mars I was in the studio
the other day with it with Bruno Mars
and oh no big deal we know each other
very well we hang out when that finesse
video came out I rarely get really
jealous but you kind of like watch it
and you're like just that's so cool
like I could never do that you know I
couldn't imagine well not with that
attitude you know replace me in the
video is it is it as cool
[Music]